[Music]
so we're gonna get a 15-minute game and
you guys see up 15 minutes on my clock
we're going to start by playing the most
common move in chess which is e4
um
the purpose of the opening is to bring
your pieces out the object of the game
of chess is to checkmate the king as you
guys know uh checkmate is a situation
where the king is being attacked and has
no squares to go to
so he plays the karo khan
which is the name of this opening where
he plays c6
let's play d4 so we grab the center with
our pawns
and he's probably going to do the same
d5
now almost all chess openings have names
they can be named after people
they can be named after
cities or
chess players or even mythical beings
most of the time they're named after
people so caro
was a person and khan was a person so
it's hyphenated karo khan
and uh black controls the center with
his pawn and if you notice black is
attacking our pawn on e4 so we need to
do something with that
um white has a bunch of possible options
here we could get the knight out to c3
we could play e5 that's the advanced
karo khan thank you unconventional or we
could take on d5
but one line that often flies under the
radar
is what's called the fantasy variation
i'm a big fan of it i recommend it to
a lot of beginners and club players the
fantasy variation is the move f3
which just defends the pawn on e4 you're
not allowing black to win your pawn
and the purpose of the fantasy is to
preserve your pawn center
the purpose of the fantasy is to
preserve your pawn center
um
yeah i i actually don't know how it got
the name fantasy variation so our
opponent takes on e4 and believe it or
not that's not a mistake but if he
doesn't follow this up correctly
it's going to end up being a bad move so
here we have a pawn trade we've got two
pawns in the center and he does follow
it up correctly with the e5
so
[Music]
this may seem if you're looking at this
for the first time like a blunder it may
seem like wait a second we can just take
the pawn with our pawn
but as i indicated it's very very
important in the opening not to forget
that if you don't develop any of your
pieces you're going to end up in trouble
this is a great example of this if we
just blindly take the pawn
who can tell me what black plays in that
position how does black punish the
greediness after d takes e5
isn't it weak to move upon protecting
the diagonal no e5 is pretty common the
king is going to castle probably yeah
queen h4 check is correct so this check
on h4 with the queen
is called a fork a fork is when one
piece attacks two or more pieces at the
same time
including the king so the queen will be
checking the king
and attacking this pawn on e4 at the
same time so we need to prevent black's
queen from coming to h
from coming to h4
in order to do that we don't just want
to do that by pushing out a pawn we want
to do that by developing a piece and
that can be accomplished with knight f3
of course black can take our pawn on d4
bishop to g4 instead by our opponent
now he develops the bishop
still taking on e5 is not a great idea
now the reason isn't that he has a check
on h4 because he doesn't
but
d takes e5 also allows a queen trade
which is very unpleasant that brings our
king out into the center we don't want
to do that
now if we think about this for a second
um
okay is black actually threatening
anything maybe he wants to take the pawn
but that's not such a big deal our goal
in this position is to develop our
pieces as actively as possible and to
very quickly prepare castling the king
castling is is a move and chess when the
king is tucked into the this side of the
board if you think about where to put
this bishop you have a couple of squares
there's e2
there's d3 there's c4
what is the most active square for the
bishop
420 from alcohol synonymous
thank you
the move is bishop c4 because the bishop
immediately aims at the f7 square this
is the weakest pawn slash the weakest
square on the chessboard very good
um and this is a super sharp opening
there's a lot going on
we want to castle we also have some
sacrifices at the ready on f7 it goes
knight to d7 that is correct
and now we need to complete our
development by castling
now we want to complete well not
complete our development but continue
our development by castling this is the
karo khan
um now which you guys should notice
particularly if
you know you're not too familiar with
chess or with these lines notice how
we're both bringing our pieces out
and notice how the bishop on c4 is
aiming at this pawn
and the rook that's sitting here on f1
is also aiming at that pawn now
obviously there's a knight in the way
but the knight is easy to move that's
our knight we can move it and if we move
our knight that f7 pawn is going to be
under a lot of fire so black has to be
super careful here thank you all of pals
gifting to puree fish
okay
so our plan
in the next couple of moves is going to
be to pile up in every way that we can
on this f7 pawn
yeah that would be me
tangido yeah and by the way guys those
of you again who are not as familiar
uh if you're not following that's okay
because after the game i'm going to go
through every move very slowly and i'm
going to explain all of the logic uh and
that's going to be more oriented toward
beginners
because i know a lot of you are sticking
around from charlie's stream i really
appreciate that and i know it can be
hard to follow when i'm making moves
quickly
so i try to cater to
all
levels
all right
this is a mistake so what he's done just
now is a big mistake
why is it a mistake
because
he doesn't defend the pawn that i've
highlighted in
in blue that pawn which i had previously
indicated is
not very well protected it's only
defended by the king and the king is a
very bad defender because once the king
is out in the open there's a greater
probability of checkmating it and we
have a very typical idea
that allows me to get a crushing attack
against this king we sacrifice the
bishop on f7 to sacrifice a piece means
to give it away bishops are obviously
stronger than pawns
so we have given up a bishop for a pawn
but we've gotten something in return as
you guys will see
this is totally crushing
now when he takes our bishop with his
king which he doesn't have to do but if
he does he moves into the path of this
rook
what does that mean that means if we
move away the night it's going to be a
check that's called a discover check so
we're going to move the knight away that
rook is going to be checking the king
and we're going to get a crushing attack
and we're going to win his bishop back
at the same time
and we're going to win his bit when his
bishop back at the same time
so if i were black i would go king to e7
i wouldn't take the bishop
although he's still losing
yeah discover checks are among the most
are among the strongest ideas that you
have at your disposal when you move a
piece out of the way of another piece
and
that results in check you can wreak
total havoc in your opponent
um so this is awesome
among us yeah oh because there's some
overlap in terminology
so
this is absolutely crushing i hope i'm
making sense by the way he can either
move the king past the bishop or he can
take the bishop he's taking his time
either way this is crushing crashing
crushing king f8
so he moves the bish of the king and i
call this the umbrella method he uses
the bishop almost as an umbrella
uh hiding behind it which is kind of
annoying
and we got to do something about it so
what should we do about it
um well there's a couple of things see
the problem is if that bishop were in
there then we would be able to move the
knight with a discovered check
if we move the knight here then we will
drop our queen and we don't want to give
away our queen
if we take his knight with our bishop
he's going to take with the king
and the king is going to be sheltered
from any discovered checks
so
we got to tone things down a little bit
we got to take a step back and say all
right let's make a simple move let's get
our bishop away from
uh away from f7
but
then comes the next question where
should we put this bishop
you can put this bishop on b3 you can
put it on c4 but if you're already
bringing the bishop back
perhaps we can distract him perhaps we
can make a move that forces him to react
and by reacting he's going to be unable
to get this king away from f8
what square am i talking about
yeah so either bishop h5
or even better bishop to e6 that's a
pretty sexy move
we're sacrificing our bishop again
but if he takes it then his king is
going to be directly in the line of fire
of the rook
that's the bottom line he can defend
with bishop takes knight that would
probably be the best move but he's still
going to be in very big trouble goes
knight f6
that's a good thought
he covers up the rook but he forgets
about his bishop now we just take his
bishop he loses a piece if he takes back
then he exposes himself once again to a
discovered check
so
hopefully this is making some sense
another thing to notice this king and
this queen where are they located they
are a night's distance away
so already you should be envisioning a
scenario where this knight lands on that
green square because that will be a fork
to the king of the queen that will win
the queen
now we need to ask ourselves how the
knight can get there how can the knight
get to this green square as quickly as
possible the blue square whatever
quickly as possible well we can go to g5
that's a check
if the king moves then he loses the
knight
and checkmate will follow if he covers
that check with his knight as he just
did then there's a fork 96 check and the
game is basically over we want his queen
when you lose your queen in chess
for no uh compensation or no other
pieces
the game is basically over oh it's thank
you for the five gifted i really
appreciate it
taking his queen
and now we are up a full queen for a
piece
how should we proceed we should simply
complete our development nothing
particularly crazy uh that we should do
here
uh before we do anything this pawn on d4
uh i want to make sure that it's well
protected so
um we can take on e5 but that would open
up a little file for his rook could we
perhaps support this pawn with another
pawn is that possible
can we try that
how can we do that we can play the move
c3 c3 just to build up a little pawn
chain making sure that our center
remains intact
some of you may say wait a second
doesn't he take this free pawn over here
well if he does that i'll talk about
what we can do
okay
i know there's a lot to talk about it
goes rook d to fa thank you call me [ __ ]
for the prime
all right
so he can test the the file
and uh
all we need to do now our center is safe
we need to complete our development look
at the bishop look at the knight they're
still on their initial squares
uh that's not a good thing they're not
doing anything first we need to deal
with the bishop what can the bishop do
well the bishop has a super nice square
on g5 where it's pinning the knight and
a pin
is a situation where one piece
is creating a situation where another
piece can't really move the knight
literally cannot move because you cannot
expose your king to an attack and that's
called a pin thank you shamrock 69 for
the five and the support today has been
unreal
thank you folks
i appreciate it shamrock
you are the man
and another sub holy pals gifting to
parker bone
thank you for the fat 10 gift subs
love it nah it's easy
my job is easy given this level of
support so bishop to g5 we still have to
develop our knight we're going to bring
it out here to d2 and maybe later on to
c4
so
another thing to point out
when you're up material and in chess
when you say material that just means
the overall collection of pieces you
have so if you're up material that means
you have more pieces than your opponent
not necessarily literally but you could
have a queen and your opponent could
have a knight for that queen and you're
still up material
so when you're up material a very common
piece of chess wisdom says that you
should trade
pieces um and the analogy that i've
thought of is like
if a soccer player gets a red card and
he gets ejected from the game
um you have 11 players against 10 right
and then some genie walks up to you and
says i'm going to make you an offer
you remove 10 players on your team
and the opposing team removes 10 players
on their team but of course one of their
players got a red card
so you get a situation where it's
literally one player
against
zero and would you take that deal if you
were the team with 11 players obviously
you would it would be easy to score a
goal
um and when you're up a queen if you
trade all of the other pieces you're
literally just going to have a queen and
maybe some pawns against a king and some
pawns and that's much easier to win than
if there's a bunch of other pieces
complicating the game
i know it's a far-fetched analogy but
maybe it helps people see why this is
inherently good so in this situation we
have a possibility of trading two
equivalent pieces we can trade a bishop
for a night the question is do we want
to do that well if we follow that advice
yes we should bishop takes knight thank
you top landers for the five i cannot
keep up with all these subs this is
crazy
all right knight takes f6
now
we still need to develop this knight
right we still need to develop this
knight let's do that let's go knight d2
we also protect the pawn
so his knight can't take it
his knight can't take the pawn because
it's protected
all right
um
so if we have a queen for two pieces
should we exchange other pieces
yeah you could now when i share chess
wisdom and again this is more geared
toward those of you who don't have much
chess experience
um when i share these pieces of advice
you got to understand that this isn't
always the case there are situations
when trading is bad even if you're up a
queen
so there are exceptions to the rules but
when you're just starting to play chess
the best thing to do thank you for the
sub kcp the best thing to do is to learn
the principles and the rules because
they're going to guide your play they're
going to make you a little bit less
overwhelmed and then when you get better
and better and more experienced you
start learning about
when the rules have exceptions and you
know you start learning more
deeper rules and stuff like that
now notice that we have a queen for a
bishop
why do you keep referring to the horses
at night because in chess this is called
the knight it is literally a horse but
uh the proper term for it is a knight
so we can do a couple of different
things look at our queen is the queen
doing anything right now
our extra queen isn't doing anything i
don't like that situation it's a pony
yeah exactly according to hicaro
okay so he's played g5 this doesn't do
very much
um
now
another important concept in chess
is the concept of a weak square
this is a little bit advanced but a weak
square
is a square that
cannot be protected by pawns
so by playing g5 he's created a very big
weak square and one of your pieces that
occupies that square is called an
outpost an outpost is a piece that
occupies a very weak square so notice
how his two pawns have passed the sixth
rank
and so this f5 square is weak it's not
protected by any pawns and it cannot be
protected by any pawns because pawns
cannot go backward these two pawns
are protecting these squares on the
fourth rank but not the squares on the
fifth rank
so we need to ask ourselves
can we get a piece to this square and
the answer is yes we can put a rook here
what is the rook doing the rook is
attacking the e5 pawn we're trying to
get him to take our d4 pawn if he does
that i'll explain why that's good for us
we could have also tried to put the
knight on that outpost we could have
done what's called a knight maneuver
maneuver is just a sequence of moves
with one piece
um knight c4 knight e3 knight f5 that
was also possible but this is even
faster
so he's taken the pawn
and
many of you guys might be tempted to
take back but in chess you always got to
look for better moves even when there's
a tempting move if you notice the bishop
and the knight they're unforkable
squares they're one square apart we've
had the situation before
we can't give a night fork but the
knight is not the only piece that can
give a fork
here we play the move e5 the bishop and
the knight are hanging and the rook most
importantly is defending that pawn so
his bishop can't take it
his bishop can't take it
i know that many of you are i i'm not
usually at this level of simplicity but
i
i you know i know there's a lot of
people from from charlie's stream and
stuff so i'm i'm sorry to those of you
who
you know for whom this is really basic
uh you know
once we continue the speedrun we'll be
back at like 1800 and stuff
thanks for being chill about it
appreciate it
okay so he's taken our pawn
now we can recapture his pawn
but that would not be a good idea
because then the bishop could move out
to c5 and deliver a check
we would have to move our king
and then he could move his knight and
then
you know the fork kind of evaporates so
instead of that
we want to take either his bishop or his
knight first that's a check
he has to respond to the check and then
we can deal with this pawn
but
we don't even have to deal with the pawn
again notice how i'm always looking for
a better move
i'm seeing the tempting move which is
just to take the pawn back
but then i'm saying wait a second is
there anything better in this position
and i'm noticing that the queen is
x-raying the king
so this knight could move out and
deliver a discovered check not just any
discover check it could deliver a double
check double check is when two pieces
are checking the king at once
and the double checks are great because
they cannot be blocked
when you deliver a double check the king
has to move
and so this is a great example of a
double check the knight is checking the
king and the queen is checking the king
so the king has to move
and we're going to
ensnare the king in a mating attack or
we're going to win a bunch of other
pieces
all right so in this position we could
take a free night
but before we even take that knight we
could make yet another intermediate move
what other intermediate move could we
make to bring another piece into
attacking position
yeah so the great move queen d6 that's a
check he can't take the queen because
it's protected by the knight he's got to
move the king back
then we take the knight
and the game is basically going to be
over
um because we're going to be up a queen
a knight and we're going to have a
mating attack so
okay so just king b6
um
yeah so we could go after the king
immediately we could go for checkmate
but let's play it simple let's just take
a free night
and then go for checkmate after that
okay i'm gonna have to run to the uh
bathroom real fast after this game guys
so you're gonna have to give me 30
seconds
i'm gonna make it quick
so
what should we do now we have checkmate
in two moves
we have checkmated two you know what i'm
gonna run to the bathroom during the
game so i'm gonna let you guys think
about the mate i'll be back in one
minute you have one minute to find the
checkmate
when i'm back i will do the big reveal
white to play and check made in two
moves it's a pretty nice one
time for the reveal john the raid thank
you time for the reveal guys
check on d7
that's a check to the king the king has
to move
and then
the queen and this is the move that's
hard to see thank you john welcome guys
i got a charlie raid earlier
this chat is hopping right now i think
you're at empty for the four months
boom goes the dynamite thank you ocho
mom peso and that's a checkmate
why is it a checkmate
because the king can't go to this side
of the board that rook covers the king
the knight covers this square and the
queen is actually doing the checking
thank you big alex
for the bits and clark payne for the
three months i appreciate it
um knight d5 would not have been made in
two
because if we did this and the knight
blocks the rook's axis to b5
alright so let's quickly go over the
game good game good game overcast i
appreciate it
yeah we're getting so much support here
i love seeing this now by the way i'll
just do a little bit of a pitch if
you're from charlie stream you like this
kind of content you want to get into
chess
there's a lot of resources out there
these days online
one of them i have a youtube channel
you can just search up my name on
youtube
and this type of speed run where i play
these slow games and explain all the
moves there's over 50 of those types of
videos on my youtube together with other
content so i would be honored if you
gave me a sub
um but only if obviously
if you like this kind of content and you
want more of it no pressure
um
thank you well i i don't compare to
charlie um but
you know but but uh i try my best to
make videos for beginners for
intermediate players so wherever you are
on the chess experience level um there's
gonna be videos for you
okay and now i will stop annoying you
with
um
stop annoying you with uh
youtube sales pitches and let's go over
the game
alright so
e4 is what i played
and overcast you played c6 this is
called the karo khan
now
the two most common chess openings are
the symmetrical move e5 the king's pawn
game thank you guys i appreciate it and
then c5 which is called the sicilian
defense
uh it's called the sicilian defense i
think because
either there was a tournament in the
italian region of sicily or there was a
chess club there that sort of pioneered
this line first thank you oats for the
gift to eat crusher bs
um and the karo khan is a super
reputable opening if you've seen queen's
gambit
uh
you probably remember benny watts kind
of trash talking to karokon but among
grandmasters it's it's a very good
opening it's considered very reputable
um
and what's the purpose behind this move
like this looks like a weird move well
black is just preparing to grab the
center with d5
um
black's preparing uh we hold much
disdain for charlotte well i'm sorry to
hear that uh lots of things but i might
talk about that later uh but black is
preparing d5 so you might be like well
why doesn't black just play here
immediately like why prepare it well the
bottom line
is that after i take the pawn you have
to take it with the queen this is called
the scandinavian the person who just
raided me john
he's a good friend of mine he's a big
fan of this opening but for beginners
it's not the best opening because you're
not supposed to bring your queen out
early what happens when you do is that
you allow your opponent to get the
pieces out with tempo what tempo just
means
while attacking
other pieces so knight c3 happens this
is an okay opening but only if you know
exactly how to play so
that's why c6 makes sense you're
preparing d5
so i decided on the fantasy variation f3
the most common lines here are to take
on d5 to push the spawn forward that's
called the advanced variation thank you
albino rhino
for the prime
and uh knight to d2 or knight to c3
those are the three most common lines
um instead i played the fantasy which is
f3
okay so d takes e4 is fine that's one of
the possible moves thank you risky play
for the prime appreciate all the subs
guys this is awesome
now black has a bunch of possible
variations here
um one of the points behind the fantasy
is that if black just gets the night out
to f6 this is not a great move who can
tell me why this move looks very natural
okay you're just developing your knight
what could be wrong with that but it
turns out that this is not a good move
because now white pushes e5 attacking
the knight the knight has to move back
to an awkward spot for example here
notice how now the knight is blocking in
the bishop and then you can really
solidify your central control with f4
notice how white has only pushed pawns
but white has built up a beautiful pawn
center even visually and then the
knight's going to come out to f3
so black has lost a bunch of tempe his
position's passive so black has to know
what to do here this isn't an opening
you could just waltz into
d take c4 is fine so the way that
overcast the way that you played is
completely legitimate this is a good
line
and again the reason that we can't take
the pawn
is because of this super nasty check
which actually which also operates as a
fork if we block the check
boom queen takes e4 another fork
and now the rook is lost
so
that's not good and so we've got to
develop our knight
and in one of the main lines if black
takes this pawn
we don't recapture we don't recapture
with a knight we don't recapture with
the queen the fantasy variation is a
very tactical line
you're ready and willing to sacrifice
pawns in order to develop your pieces
quickly and if you are paying careful
attention to the way that the game is
going you should already have an inkling
about what i should do here we should
continue developing our pieces disregard
the pawn get this bishop out to c4
what's the idea the idea is to
immediately pile up on this pawn
now
a quick little overview of ford
geography for those of you who are new
to the game
what i'm drawing with my vertical arrows
are called files in russian you can
literally call them a vertical but in
english they're called files
the horizontal parts of the board are
called ranks
and files are very important because
they can be used as a conduit from your
position to your opponent's position you
could put rooks and queens on files
because they are the only types of
pieces that move in a straight line or
that control squares in a straight line
and in chess there is a very important
concept of open files an open file
every when the game begins every file is
closed what does it mean for a file to
be closed it means there are pawns on
every single file
as soon as a pawn disappears from a file
that file becomes semi-open
if both pawns disappear from a file it
becomes open a semi-open file is a file
that only benefits one player
and here's the the cool part
if your pawn disappears from a file that
could benefit you why because if we fast
forward now
uh to this position this f2 pawn has
disappeared from this square so when we
put a rook on f1
that rook is unobstructedly that's not
even a word um it's 2am i'm exhausted
that rook is
um is staring at this f7 pawn and it's
not blocked by your own pawn on f2 but
you guys get what i'm trying to say
um if we started with no pawns it would
be crazy
uh craziness would ensue so just a
little quick overview into files and how
they work i hope i just made sense
please don't feel uh shy about asking
questions even if you're a beginner
everyone's always welcome so i want to
make sure everybody understands what i'm
saying
unobstructedly is a word apparently yeah
so bishop g4 is my opponent's
my opponent's response
now um this is this would be very
dangerous now the move that i recommend
to karokon players this is a slightly
more advanced point
is bishop to e6
developing the bishop but not to where
he developed it rather developing it to
the red square thank you um manambo
jambo for the prime
what's the purpose of this weird
developing move well the first thing to
understand
doesn't this just hang upon doesn't this
allow us to take the pawn well if you
remember previously now you have this
check on h4 again you win back the pawn
with interest so you can't take that
pawn with the knight
you can take it with a pawn but that
allows the queen trade forces the king
out to the open file and gives black a
super comfortable game for the pun
when
you have a lot of stuff in return for
the pawn when you've got
you know an attack for example that's
called compensation you have
compensation for the pawn that just
means you've got stuff going on in the
position
that gives you enough
uh
you know that that can be used in
regular english doing enough
compensation for the pawn thank you mick
finnegan for the prime
so we don't want to take this pawn with
either piece instead we want to do what
we did in the game but much later which
is to play c3
uh supporting our central pawn so that
if he takes we could simply recapture
with a pawn and the game goes on black
goes knight d7 and develops the knight
we develop the bishop black develops
tonight both sides complete their
development i just think that this is a
very solid line for black which
won't allow you to get blown off the
board
so back to the game bishop g4 bishop c4
very dangerous move aiming at the f7
pawn
this also creates a threat and in chess
a threat
just like it is in real life is
something that
if your opponent doesn't stop you you're
going to do and cause damage
this move creates a threat so let's make
a random move for black to understand
what the threat is
to understand what the threat is you
need to understand two two subsequent
things two preliminary things the first
is the purpose of this move which as i
explained is to aim at this very weak
pawn on f7 the second thing to
understand is that this bishop on g4 is
undefended
that means it has no pieces or pawns
that are protecting it which means that
it's incredibly vulnerable to things
like a fork right
now you might look at this and say okay
so let's take on e5 let's let's attack
the bishop but it's too early for that
because the knight is pinned if you move
the knight you lose your queen can't do
that what you can do is you can take on
f7 with the bishop sacking it luring the
king to f7
now after knight takes e5 wait we're
blundering the queen but no we're not
the king is now in check and we fork
that very same bishop which is
unprotected so
this is a very common pattern and if
you're a beginner and you're feeling
overwhelmed remember that when you learn
this stuff you learn patterns
you might have a completely different
position
but you might still find an idea of this
sort
uh even if it's wearing completely
different clothes so you learn by
acquiring patterns and then pattern
recognition kind of sets in after you
become more experienced
so knight to d7 is a good move from that
perspective
now you might ask well wait a second why
can't we do the same thing
okay let's try takes f7
looks like we can do the same thing we
can just take on e5 we're in great shape
but no he takes on e5
and the problem is that our queen is
hanging and that very same knight is
protecting the bishop so we lose not one
but two pieces that's way too much to
give up
a slightly more advanced question what
about this move why can't we give this
check because hey the knight is
protected by the bishop the king has to
move and then we take the bishop and
we're up a pawn and the king is terrible
but that's not right because the queen
can take the knight the point is that
white's queen is hanging as well
uh and this creates a situation where
both queens are hanging
if we take black's queen he takes our
queen we've sacrificed two pieces he's
only given up one and so black is up a
piece here this is
unfortunately insufficient
um
so we can't take here for that reason we
have to play patiently and for that
reason we castled
this reinforces the threat of bishop
takes f7 by creating a rook x-ray
against that square
and in this position decisive mistake
was made by our opponent bishop to d6
it's good from a general level it's a
development move
but it's bad specifically because it
does not protect uh
this pawn from the x-ray of the rook how
should blackup developed to protect the
pawn from the rook's x-ray what should
black have played here
yes knight f6 is correct
thank you for the subtle mama knight f6
is correct
and so
once again after takes takes
we can move our we can do this but it
doesn't do anything
because there's a knight on f6 if there
was no knight on f6 this would have been
a double check as it was in the game
um
i almost played knight f6 but was scared
of d takes e5 thanks for letting me know
who can tell me how black can solve this
situation what should black do here
because indeed if you take on e5 with
the knight
then we take the queen first and then
that's a free knight
but black is an intermediate move that's
very important
what can black do before taking on e5
no it's black to play
so
we're asking what happens if i take his
pawn black can take the knight first he
takes the knight first
we have to respond to that because the
queen is going to be hanging
and after we take the bishop
then he takes the pawn the knight is now
is now safe
and this creates a little mini fork
against white's bishop black is in great
shape here white doesn't have to lose a
piece we can swing the queen around and
protect the bishop but black's got a
great developing game here bishop c5
check is also possible you can start
with this check that's that's true and
then you have but you'll have to do the
same thing
so
looking for intermediate moves is very
important in such positions and here
once we take on f7 the game is over
because
basically over because if he takes the
bishop
we take on e5 that's a double check
then we take the bishop
um
chess speed run yeah sure so in a chest
speed on
i start with a rating of zero i
basically start from a beginner's chess
rating and i climb all the way up to
master or grandmaster level now i have a
normal account where my rating is
reflective
of the average rating of a grandmaster
in a speed run i start from scratch and
build my way upward so that i can
experience playing beginners right
normally i don't play beginners but in a
speeder and i play beginners to explain
the method that i used to beat them
basically
um
so we have questions doesn't queen b6
work
um queen b6 is fine but again after king
h1 oh yeah you can you can do that yeah
that's possible
this is also possible because now the
queen can no longer be captured good
great catch
um
so he has to sidestep the check so king
f8 was a good move
unfortunately it doesn't quite cut it
and this move bishop e6 was the decisive
move
uh but there's
one thing to unpack here
let's say he had accepted the sacrifice
could somebody remind me what white's
idea is
and why it may seem like this actually
fails for white white's next move is
pretty obvious
but after that black has a very strong
response or so it seems
so knight g5
exposing the attack against the king it
may seem oh he has to cover the check
then we take the bishop much like we did
in the game and it's a fork and that's a
win
but uh he can play king e7 he can move
the king away
and
wait a second what's going on here the
bishop is protected by the king this is
no longer a fork
uh is there a difference between knight
g5 and oh
yeah not really knight g5 would be very
straight the only difference is that it
wins another pawn why not right why not
take another pawn if you can but in
reality uh this is the same thing knight
595 doesn't make a big difference king
fav bishop b6 takes
knight g5 king e7 but if you calculate a
little bit further if you try to
anticipate just a couple more moves
ahead let's consider what happens if we
take the bishop anyway
king takes the the knight but now this
king is incredibly vulnerable for a king
to be vulnerable it means it's in the
center it's unprotected there's no pawn
shell around it so it's susceptible to
all sorts of checks and potential mates
and it turns out that white has
checkmate in three moves
yeah my opponents so on my old my other
speedrun account my name was stated on
the page but
chess.com is aware that i'm doing it
after what they refund ratings of my
opponents thank you griff graham for the
five gifted i appreciate it
so the move is queen g4 check
the king drops back to e7 that is forced
queen takes g7 check another check
king has to go back or forward doesn't
matter and we give checkmate on f7 what
is responsible for all of this existing
it's the rook on f1 so that's why the
fantasy variation is so good if we
rewind all the way back to this trade it
might not seem like a significant trade
but it opens up the f file it creates a
semi-open file that's responsible for
all of these attacking ideas
all right
so for that reason taking the bishop
would have been impossible knight gf6 is
a good attempt unfortunately it doesn't
work bishop takes bishop knight takes
knight she five check and this is
totally crushing the lesser evil would
have been to give away the knight
instead of giving away the queen
it wouldn't have helped we still have a
completely overwhelming attack so this
is totally crushing
and the rest of the game i can go over
but it was very simple once we win the
queen
and support our center the last thing i
want to point out here
what would have happened if he takes
this pawn on e4
how would we have responded
if uh if he had snapped off that pawn
one of the things you should ask
yourself
is well what squares are no longer under
black's control what squares are now
accessible to us then you immediately
should see queen g4 four king the knight
and the pawn on g7 this game is
basically over
um so that's why we left this pawn
hanging
now we got our bishop out we trade it we
got our knight out we occupy the outpost
on f5
a very weak square and now we go in for
the final kill we just win one of
black's pieces and the rest is very easy
uh so
the rest is easy we take the bishop we
deliver a discovered double check
against the king the knight and the
queen are both giving the check here
we drive the queen into d6 another
intermediate move
um
no it's much more important to develop
understanding than to memorize the
opening what if king e6 after the pawn
fork
so if king e6 we can take the knight
with a rook so we take the knight with a
rook and the pawn protects the rook so
we're still going to win a piece here
thank you puns gifting to monaco
so e5 dc
ed check king d6 double check driving
the queen in taking the knight and now
the check made in two moves
check driving the king to the corner and
sliding the queen back to a3
delivering the checkmate
um
so
let's let the
truck pass
um is it really interesting to occupy an
outpost with a rook rather than a knight
so generally speaking outposts are best
occupied by knights that is true
uh however in this specific instance uh
there were
you know basically extenuating
circumstances because this pawn on e5 if
you look at it is being attacked by the
rook so there was a very specific reason
to put the rook on an outpost and if he
takes then we give a fork if you wanted
to put a knight on this outpost you had
to drag it through c4 and then e3 and
then f5 and that would have been very
possible
but i wanted to operate a little bit
faster than that okay
and that was what a speedrun game looks
like now generally speaking we don't
analyze speedrun games nearly
with this level of
detail
but since we had a charlie red and stuff
today was an exception
once again uh there's tons of speedrun
videos on youtube
and uh you're welcome to help yourselves
to that
all right guys i'm pretty exhausted i i
know we've got still got a big crowd but
i'm gonna give somebody a big raid i'm
i'm
going to hit the sack
um
and i'll be back tomorrow i've
in preparation for the tournament i'm
trying to
uh keep a slightly more responsible
schedule
so i hope that's okay with everybody
again it's a pleasure to see so many of
you from charlie stream sticking around
really it's awesome
so i really appreciate it guys
uh and all of the support today
it's been awesome i hope you had a great
memorial day
and uh yeah thank you the the feedback
from the speedrun is always very
heartwarming
[Music]